Donald Trump's impeachment trial starts today.
Now we're going to talk about in a bit after
the break, what is the argument that Donald
Trump is making about the impeachment?
What is the argument that his lawyers will
make about the impeachment?
But first, let's talk about what should happen
in this impeachment.
If this was a fair world where actions had
consequences, even if you're the president,
there should be probably a secret ballot for
impeachment so that senators would not be
bullied into voting to acquit merely to avoid
what might be the political consequences.
There should be a secret ballot and there
should be a unanimous conviction of Donald
Trump based on the evidence that we've seen.
Now, there's a really good article, an op
ed in the Hill, I hope.
Pronouncing his last name correctly, it's
Douglas Mique, CMYK.
I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly, and
Douglas points out that the entire argument
that will take up the first day in today's
Senate impeachment trial, which is is the
impeachment trial even constitutional, that
is not the duty of the Senate to determine
the duty of the Senate is not to determine
whether this is constitutional.
First of all, it is.
And secondly, why would you put many non scholars,
nonlegal professionals in a position of deciding
about the constitutionality of something?
It really doesn't make sense.
What jurors in the Senate should be determining
is whether Donald Trump could reasonably foresee
that the consequences of him saying it's all
rigged for a month or two months.
Let's go down to the capital.
We're marching down to the capital.
Rudy Giuliani, you know, trial by combat,
all of this stuff.
Could it was it foreseeable that the uncontested
reality of what took place was something that
that was likely to take place?
That is what the determination ultimately
needs to be.
Donald Trump doesn't have the law on his side
when it comes to avoiding impeachment because
of the constitutional issue.
But in any case, that's not really what the
Senate should be deciding.
And there is really no disagreement about
what took place on January six.
This Douglas Kmiec points out, even Trump's
defense team acknowledges the facts of what
took place on January 6th, which was a violent
insurrection attempt at the U.S. Capitol.
So then it becomes a question of really common
sense.
Remember, this is not a court of law.
The Senate was was it reasonable for Donald
Trump to foresee what took place?
And it's very hard to imagine that the answer
is no.
Donald Trump was reportedly gleeful in the
early hours of the insurrection, Donald Trump
reportedly resisted sending law enforcement,
which would have quelled or limited what took
place.
And only when Donald Trump was convinced that
the political consequences could be too grave.
Did he come out and give that mealy mouthed
sort of statement about, oh, we've got to
be peaceful in all of this stuff.
So that's what should happen.
Trump won't be convicted and the voting won't
be by secret ballot.
I was I was actually thinking, imagine that
there was a secret ballot where instead of
voting out loud publicly, senators voted secretly.
Imagine that you end up with 80 votes to convict.
So, you know, 30 Republicans voted to convict,
but none of them are willing to admit it.
You know what would happen, right?
They would, again, start with voter fraud,
supposedly 80 votes to convict.
And we can't find a single Republican willing
to say, yes, I voted to convict.
But you know what?
It's going to be a moot point because they're
not going to convict.
And then it will be up to voters to determine
whether they care enough to force consequences
upon these Republican senators in the 2022
election.
Now, as a as a reminder, when we talk about
representative democracy, a majority of Americans
say that Donald Trump should be convicted
and barred from holding office in the future.
Fifty six percent of Americans we looked at
that ABC poll yesterday.
Trump's lawyers are saying that the entire
trial is merely political theater and the
arguments that they are making in their early
legal brief and we will see today and tomorrow
more so how they actually make this case a
reality.
They are both saying that the entire process
is unconstitutional and that the House impeachment
vote was extraordinarily biased.
And they are going to say that this is censorship
and it's an attempt to silence Donald Trump.
And of course, that's not what it is.
Donald Trump was able to say whatever the
hell he wanted.
And now there may be consequences to him saying
that, remember, free speech doesn't mean freedom
from all consequences to your speech.
One other little note.
Apparently, Trump's defense team is planning
to show clips of what they say are examples
of Democrats urging violence from last year.
So I think that there's going to be a lot
of interesting moments during this.
But ultimately, we are going to get the political
theater is going to be Trump's defense.
We are going to get an acquittal.
And then ultimately we will see if the American
people decide that these Republican senators
need to be held accountable.
The American public often has a short memory.
So I am not particularly optimistic that Republican
senators who have prejudged this and already
know they are going to acquit will be held
accountable.
It would be nice if they were, but I don't
anticipate that.
And we will be live streaming the impeachment
on the David Pakman show, YouTube Twitch and
Facebook channels.
I hope you'll join me.
But in the meantime, let me know via Twitter
what you expect to see in this trial.
You can find me on.
Twitter at David Pakman